[Music]
being justifying murder news yeah
submitted by Nat King Cole oh my god
really yeah that's amazing
with us a man has a strange defense in a
double murder death penalty case double
murder dead what's a double murder at
the boom boom double murder like boom
boom yeah why was that so hard to figure
out I thought for some reason like he
killed somebody and then he tried to
kill them again when they're already
dead Yoko he's already dead bro that's
why maybe we should all go to school
it's a double murder death penalty not
double murder death went in to explain
something to you it's over dude you can
leave how dare you insult it like that I
got you the clammy not sweaty clammy
very wet your body already is
particularly that's like three ounces of
watery I have a theory that the universe
balances himself out I never drink
energy drinks I'm having one you're
drinking water
oh you're right yeah yeah look at that
switch are you sweaty bro alright so
this story here writing takeout okay
good Steve just running yeah exactly
what just running [ __ ] Steve remember to
say [ __ ] Steve liver yeah all right take
out all his tanks everything he has no
credit into the description anyway so
this story's about this man named
Kenneth he was arrested in March 2012
but the reason why we're talking about
him now is because his defense as to why
he killed his sister-in-law and her
boyfriend is saying because I am told
you made him do it
I freakin believe it see that's the
problem right Scientology's become such
a thing in our vernacular
when you hear it you're like oh I think
it could be associated with period yeah
if I kill somebody I might use that
excuse
Scientology made me do it what's the
Twinkie defense
yeah so this guy was gonna get sentenced
I don't know what he said for maybe for
murder or whatever for life um and he
just ate a bunch of Twinkies and he that
was his defense that he was crazy
like what no the to Hakeem 82 years at
work yeah a Twinkie yeah yeah and he was
just like he was just like I'm just
crazy just like I'm crazy and all he did
was just eat well I guess a lot of
youtubers are crazy then us included no
because these are the ones that eat
Twinkies okay challenge that's a good
thing yeah like you know like like
competitive food we've done us included
cuz we've got you before oh my god why
does this always happen it's okay
this conversations got to be worth let's
continue Twinkies are good but yeah
let's keep going yeah let's keep going
guys so so this man what he did is he
drove from Missouri his from his home in
rural Missouri all the way to Arizona
and I before it was more than a 20 like
24 hour plus Drive ha he didn't sleep he
was on meth I bet you yeah so what he
did is he went there he had been
bludgeoned them to death Oh
poured acid on them and then set the
house on fire oh damn
oh wait what'd you say he had acid
apparently he had cheated or hatched I
don't know what I think the point is he
used the hatch he used to hatch oh he
used the hatchet gotcha I was like what
the [ __ ] why are there eggs here dude
what the [ __ ] is going on he used it won
the amount of eggs yeah so he did this
one because it's a hatchet
you're [ __ ] serious if it's a hatchet
you're [ __ ] with so what is it
hatched how can the word disorder
a computer it's a hatchet well yeah it's
a hatchet right hu [ __ ] how to use the
verb of a hatchet hatchet it yeah right
that's unsafe hatchet is all you guys
are stupid is hatchet aid right I bet
you it's something else like how do you
use a hatchet in the past
yeah exactly good for you all right I
got a [ __ ] no though I'm gonna find
out how tradition cuz I just say axed
yeah and if that's wrong what the [ __ ] a
hatchet they're different
pretty much what for trying to be
clearly okay I'll bite the difference
hatchet is a very small axe wall be
[ __ ] down bro that's why people why
me of all people I ask questions when I
have questions I don't pretend to know
my white Scout masters they're like
little cheeky boy hatchet is not a next
do you mean scout master or slave master
dude what's going on there's an
Australian article writer
that's what she was saying [ __ ]
around so I kept up eating their eggs
double-murder hatchet or hatcheted I
mean whatever just happens next
anyway yeah he had to did and bludgeoned
them to death
don't be French blue jean and they got
the acid and they just poured it on that
[ __ ] by how do people keep on
doing this acid thing they're like we
put bodies in these containers filled
with acid I like were these [ __ ] yes
yeah weird even by that [ __ ] yeah
suspicious of people who own barrels of
acid yeah you're right I'll be like can
I get a barrel and some acid and they're
like hey I have another question I mean
yeah like I don't understand where that
happened right so he said that the
reason why he did this is because his
sister-in-law she has two children one
of them she put like the nephew his
nephew why does he even care about his
sister-in-law
cuz he's explaining she's right now yeah
so okay but like what happened okay so
the nephew was placed in a hospital for
for like behavioral issues so for
Scientologists they believe that
psychology is like all like the most
evilest thing in this planet like you
should never seek mental health food
like from a psychologist or any other
well you need to be cleared is what they
think Ministry of death
yes that's what they believe and so you
gotta use a meters and [ __ ] that's
what's gonna really help you as awesome
have you been to the Ministry of death
Museum no where's that it's the it's in
Hollywood I think and it's a solid blue
building yeah yeah I know I don't know
if it's blue but the science Scientology
put put on a museum this really like
[ __ ] psychiatry and here's how it [ __ ]
you often like they had the thing with
the padlock dog experian where they have
the the scientists yeah and there's
drooling out of his mouth or surface I
heard with the Bell yeah yeah
have all this [ __ ] where they used to do
like lobotomies yeah yeah yeah
so they also Scientology also teaches
that quote what people will not discuss
over the phone or even during a
scheduled face-to-face meeting they will
agree to discuss if you show up cold at
their door and so that's why the defense
is saying that that's why he just out of
the blue just randomly decided to go to
Arizona
instead of Tennessee where he was gonna
check on some parents property or
something so his wife thought that she
was going to Tennessee which is her
sister by the way and so she ended up
going Arizona trying to rescue these
children from from all of that like
happy psychology all that [ __ ] so he
ended up killing them turn the kids no
no not the kid luckily the kids were not
there cuz when I was in the hospital the
other one was staying somewhere else
with some friends or other family and so
yeah he arrived and killed the
sister-in-law and her boyfriend and then
after that he ended up driving away and
there was a cop on the freeway that
noticed that he was just driving really
weird cuz his arms are stiff and he was
just like this I'm just driving
intensely that's always and women
driving though I think don't they drive
like this who's steering wheel's like
literally right here I seem like it's so
stiff no if now that I pointed it out
you're gonna see it okay I've seen a no
mistake their arms through the steering
wheel of home and then the whole day
like my grandma drives like this the
steering wheels up and she's also
sitting on a car seat thing that gives
you a little boost like a pillow yeah
she showed me my apology she's little
like 4 years old she's like 5 foot 2 or
some [ __ ]
my grandma's tiny baby and she has a big
Cadillac or something yeah dude Lincoln
a Lincoln Town Car could [ __ ] mow
down it could drive through someone's
house and she wouldn't even know people
drive Oh danger but yeah so his arms are
like locked out he was gripping the
steering wheel so the trooper when he
pulled him over he had this
drug drug sniffing dog with him and so
the dog kind of signaled to him that
there was something the barrel under the
[ __ ] neck and so the trooper said
that he also smelled a solvent in the
car and then he spotted a red gas can
there as well so then started searching
the car then he found the hatchet in the
trunk yeah so there was but so his
excuse was that he and suppose sucks at
killing
yes he's saying that he was volunteering
and killing at a wildlife park around
feeding time and then a worker flung
meat into the cages and he ended up
getting blood splattered on his clothes
to change pants and so he found a pair
of pants the trooper found a pair of
pants of blood on them and then the
hatchet was covered in blood and what
appeared to be the long human hair oh my
god it's like yeah I got a nosebleed man
yeah just [ __ ] my nose was bleeding
what about this long hair watch my nose
hairs I gave it but got a long nose here
yeah and this look he also asks I'm a
butcher and that was a yak yes if you
could retreat retrieve a water bottle
from a backpack in the car but instead
of a water bottle a lot of times I'm gun
in there yeah and you try to kill the
cop well luckily the cop looked first
before you okay oh is this your water
bottle [ __ ] dude there's something
like you dick owes any of you wire man
what the [ __ ] is interested you yeah
yeah so then that's when the trooper
radio dispatch to see there was any
unusual activity in the area and that's
when police and firemen had responded to
the house fire cuz he said oh and then
they found two bodies inside that were
hacked to death it's hot
oh yeah that's the word what hatcheted
is actually a word - it only took 12 and
a half minutes to figure out no articles
pretty long I just scroll to like find
that yes this said Hector Sonakshi oh
there are six brains in this room
allegedly my face we're all very tired
people
witnesses described seeing a white car
leaving and he was driving a white Ford
car tourists are Taro's Porto ruse no
it's not yeah so that's that story photo
oh how come his face is so small i buy
it but then the prosecutors are saying
like hold on like he hasn't even
practiced Scientology because he mom
married when he was a kid his mom
married someone that is a Scientologist
and so he did practice it a bit like
when he was a kid but then when he was
an adult he denounced it and so they
were like he can't even use that defense
so Santa Rosa Scientology is like it
next tried it we don't we don't do that
stupid grace you know all that [ __ ] man
you got excommunicated because if you
leave the church you're out yeah like
you're [ __ ] dead so you can't talk to
any family members or nothing that's
very good which church Scientology if
you leave you're out and anyone who's in
can't talk to you anymore
yeah it's Paris all cut yeah that's
great like you're not gonna get a chance
to meet Zeno it's like how the church
used to be like the Catholic Church in
[ __ ] oh you're leaving our church like
you're excommunicated and then family's
like rotten to you you're not God you're
not is what they called me with second
yeah I did I'm just thinking about
everyone watching this video and while
we were doing the hatcheted whole thing
they're like it's hacks people
no no they knew the commenters always
know the comment has always had all the
answers and we don't have them sorry
guys is all my fault no we're not sorry
for [ __ ] alright I'm not sorry yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry that she sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]